vpe is the new normal in high-risk
surgery but what they've done at this
cancer hospital is anything but routine
we operate in a different way but the
results are good as good as comparable
and causes here most hospitals have
canceled cancer surgery but University
College London has shielded one of its
buildings from the virus only cancer
patients who test negative the code 19
are admitted staff to our regularly
screened and operating theatres are deep
cleaned so despite having the PPE with
all the risks thought we're minimizing
this is working and functioning very
well results from the first 500 patients
who've had surgery at the hospital
during the peak of the pandemic show
just 10 were diagnosed with a virus in
the weeks that followed none died
studies from Wuhan early on in the
epidemic showed that one in five
patients having operations died soon
after if they have the corona virus and
that's largely because surgery in itself
can affect the immune system but here
they have found a way of working that
reduces the risk to zero many cancer
services have been suspended during the
pandemic because the risk of coming into
hospital was thought to be too high for
vulnerable patients but there is now a
backlog of thousands of operations and
delays in treatment can cost lives if
you reduce the chances of coverage
entering the hospital you can continue
with high-volume urgent and cancer
surgery with good outcomes for patients
which is particularly important because
we know globally about two million
operations are being canceled a week so
there's a lot of need for this to be
able to continue and hopefully other
sites can learn from what we've done
everybody's very happy to see that
you're doing so well Tim Robinson had
surgery 10 days ago the safety measures
at the hospital gave him peace of mind
there was all sorts of fears you just
can't afford to delay the hospitals are
doing a fantastic job
if you follow the coded cleaning don't
touch your mouth all the sort of things
you're you're going to be in safe hands
the coronavirus is likely to return in
at least one more wave in the coming
months
what medics have proved here is that
vital surgery can continue even in these
difficult times Thomas More Sky News